I think when somebody writes the history
of our time 250 years from now the two
largest stories in it will be the rise
of Asia in the developing world we're
living standards are increasing so
spectacularly rapidly that in a matter
of a few decades countries enjoy more
growth than the United States has since
the American Revolution how that impacts
the billions of people in these
countries and how that impacts the world
system and I think the second defining
feature of our time will be the
developments in the life sciences that
are going to profoundly change our
conceptions of human nature that are
going to free people from pain and
suffering a rate and on a scale that has
never been seen before you know we are
increasingly developing the capacity to
change the way people think to change
the way people behave how we're going to
manage all of that how we're going to
manage the life science side of all of
that how we're going to manage the
remarkable things that are happening in
information technology and as those
things come together these two things I
think will be the central stories of our
time when histories written 250 years